>> Hi, everyone. Thanks for coming.
Appreciate you guys taking time out of your
day.
My name is Erica Fox.
I'm a manager in Google University, and it's
my great pleasure and honor to introduce my
friend, Ngahihi o te ra Bidois and affectionately
known as Ngahi.
Ngahi is an indigenous native Maori from New
Zealand.
And he's just published a book called, "Ancient
Wisdom, Modern Solutions." about his quest
to become a modern day warrior.
I met Ngahi in May in Kuala Lumpur.
We were both speaking at a human resources
conference where we were kind of sharing some
innovative and best practice ideas around
all sorts of human resources topics.
And I heard Ngahi give a presentation and
a speech about leadership, and particularly,
about what leadership means in the Maori culture.
And I just thought it was something so interesting
and that would resonate with Google.
So I invited him here.
So, without further ado, I'd like to introduce
Ngahi.
>> [Clapping]
Ngahi Bidois: [chanting in Maori] Now,
just in case any of you have no idea what
I just said, I brought along a dictionary
and -- the reality is, if I gave you the dictionary,
it wouldn't make any sense.
And hopefully, I'll be able to explain things
a lot better in person.
And, of course, I've written a book about
it as well.
But, we have come from New Zealand.
This is our first time here in New York, and
it is a real privilege to be here.
My name is Ngahihi o te ra Bidois, as Erica
said.
Ngahihi o te ra is Maori.
It means "the rays of the sun".
Bidois is French. It means "handsome". [laughter]
"Highly intelligent", and there was another
one I keep forgetting -- ah, that's right
-- "humble".
And I still have not met a Bidois who disagrees
with me.
It's really good to be here in your beautiful
city.
And my wife and I -- a few years ago now -- were
sitting in our lounge and watching TV.
And as we were watching TV, we were crying,
because it was the 11th of September.
And we have had the privilege of attending
and going to a memorial while we've been here
over in the county of Wayne in New Jersey,
with our hosts -- with Karen and Mark -- who
are hosting us.
And I remember standing in the middle of that
memorial, and I was crying for the things
that have happened in your beautiful nation.
And for us to be here in the midst of New
York so many years later, to say to you, [speaking
in Maori], [translating] "From our people,
the Maori people, I give you our sympathy
and our deepest wishes for those of you who
I know may be still hurting."
And, in our culture, it is appropriate that
we acknowledge those who have passed in your
culture.
And so, I do that, [speaking in Maori] I greet
you once. [in Maori] I greet you twice. [in
Maori] I greet you three times. [in Maori]
I'm aware that there are three kinds of people
in this audience today.
First, obviously, visual learners -- and we're
going to fly through some Powerpoint presentations
behind me to help you, because you learn by
seeing and by reading.
Audible listeners -- we'll be telling a few
stories along the way.
And the final group of learners amongst you
are obviously kinesthetic.
So, for the kinesthetic listeners -- and this
is just to prove that I met Erica in Singapore,
at the HID Congress Conference -- and, I must
admit, Erica was just an outstanding ambassador
for Google, not only on the stage, but off
the stage as well.
And she was one of the celebrity speakers
of the engagement.
And at times, we felt more like bodyguards,
and it was really nice to meet you there,
Erica, and great to be here today as well.
I would like to ask everyone to please stand
for the kinesthetic learners.
I had a friend who was dying.
And it was the last time that I would meet
him -- see him -- on this earth.
And in Maoridom, we call this 'nohaki'.
And as I was talking to him, I said, "You
know, I'm finding it very difficult that you're
going to be leaving and I don't think I can
survive."
And he said to me, "Ngahi, every answer that
you will ever need in your life can be found
if you look in the mirror. And if you ask
the right questions of the person looking
back at you, you will have the answer to every
problem that you face."
And what I'm going to do today is just encourage
you to look into your mirror.
And we're going to be looking at proverbs,
people, and purpose.
But, I'm going to ask you questions and I
don't want to know the answer, but I want
you to think about that question and think
about the answer for yourself.
Are you ready for your first question?
[pause] Why am I standing?
Ask yourself, "Why am I standing?" What has
happened -- many of you have never met -- in
fact, I'd say I've only met half a dozen of
you in this room.
There are things that I have done to influence
your behavior.
And as John C Maxwell, one of your leadership
gurus, says, "The true measure of leadership
is influence -- nothing more, nothing less."
And all we're going to do today is look at
three ways to increase your influence.
And as I said earlier, we're going to look
at proverbs, people, and purpose.
And the importance of those when it comes
to influence.
You may now be seated.
Unless you choose not to, and -- I would also
like to take this opportunity to thank Google.
I come from a group of people known as the
Maori race in New Zealand.
We are the indigenous people of New Zealand.
And not that long ago, Craig -- in association
with some people from my home city in Rotorua
-- developed Google in Maori.
And that enabled my children, for example
-- who attend an education institute where
their first language of instruction is Maori
-- to be able to get on their computers and
Google in their indigenous language.
And for them to be able to do that has not
only opened a whole new world for them from
very young age, but it has given us as people
what we call 'manah'.
It has given us prestige.
It has given us a sense of belonging, because
you made our language -- which was also already
an official language of New Zealand -- more
official.
So I would like to take this opportunity as
well to thank you at Google, because I know
that you all would have had a part to play
in it for making it possible for us to Google
in our official language.
So we're going to look quickly at three ways
to increase your influence.
How many of you have been to prison?
I actually don't expect you to answer it.
[laughter]
I do see the hand down the back though.
Oh, sorry, you're eating your -- yeah, yeah.
I have.
And it's about now Erica and the others think,
"Uh-oh, that wasn't on the form."
But the prison I went to was not a prison
of concrete walls and steel bars; it was the
prison of my mind.
And this prison looked like this.
When I was young, I saw a helicopter flying
above and it had Santa Claus in it who was
throwing us lollies.
And I said to one of my mates, as we're picking
up these lollies, "I'm going to fly in one
of those one day."
And they looked at me and said, "Yeah right,
Ngahi. Few too many lollies, I think."
It goes like this.
People in my life saying, "Ngahi, your life
will never amount to anything.
You? Go to university? I don't think so.
You didn't even pass the national exams that
we have.
You? Write a book? You can't even write proper
essays.
You? Speak to people? Wasn't it that day that
you skipped school or were very sick because
there was speech contests on at school? I
don't think so."
So all of these bars, [chufe!] [chufe!] [chufe!]
were being put around my mind.
And people would say things like, "You can't
do that. You just can't do that."
[chufe!] There's another bar.
And it got to the stage that, whenever I went
to go and do something, all I could see was
a bar in front of me, stopping me from achieving
anything -- until an incredible thing happened
in my life.
I stayed with my grandmother for two years.
And in those two years, she taught me an incredible
proverb.
And that proverb was, [speaking in Maori]
[translating], "The thought creates the person."
And she said this to me, "Ngahi, it doesn't
matter what other people think of you.
What matters is what you think of you."
And then, she would give me a big hug, and
she'd say, "And, by the way, I think you can
do anything."
[speaking in Maori] There's another man who
was a hero in my life, and his name was Bruce
Lee. Have you heard of Bruce Lee? Yeah. Yeah.
Bruce Lee said this, "As we think, so shall
we become."
In fact, if you'd have seen Bruce Lee, he
would have said it like this, "As we think,
so shall we become."
I think it was the dubbing of the movies that
was -- And if a man who was known for his
physical prowess would say something like
that, and remind us that, "As we think, so
shall we become," then how important is it
for us to keep thinking as well?
Leaders think, and thinkers lead.
So, for you as leaders, I would like to say
this.
I believe you are paid to think more than
any other skill you have.
And walking around your building, it was just
so wonderful to see the many places where
you can think -- opportunities that you have
to think in this very building.
Leonard Ravenhill said, "Opportunities of
a lifetime must be seized in the lifetime
of the opportunity."
And you have so many opportunities here every
day to think.
Here's something for you to think about.
Who are my eagles?
Look in your mirror and say, "Who are my eagles?
Who are my mentors?
Who are the people who get me from A to B?"
Because you will be the same person in five
years time except for two things.
One, the information that you learn. And two,
the people that you meet.
Let's take an example of that.
Think of your five best friends.
It is highly likely that your income is their
average.
So you want to earn more money?
Dump your friends and get -- nah, nah.
You want to be a better leader?
Look to leaders that you want to be like and
ask them to mentor you.
Ask them to be your eagles.
Eagle -- as many of you will know -- is an
amazing bird.
It has in its wing a bone that it locks.
And it locks this wing as the storm approaches,
and can fly above storms.
Eagles have been seen at over 15,000 feet
by airline pilots.
They fly so high, that ice starts forming
on their backs.
And their wings are locked up here above the
storm.
And they're able to descend down the other
side of the storm as well.
Guess who the storm hurts?
Yep. All the turkeys.
You guys have heard of that saying?
"How can I fly like an eagle when I'm surrounded
by turkeys?" Well, where are the eagles?
They're up here.
So when you are working those long hours,
take note of who else is working with you.
When you are doing those hard jobs that allow
you to fly above the storm, take note of the
other eagles who are flying above the storm
with you.
Go and meet them. Get to know them.
They will make you a better person.
So, who are my eagles?
Let's keep moving.
"Do I think like a leader?" is your next question.
Remembering the things that I've seen around
here in Google as well -- you just think way
outside of the box or the square or the circle
or the star, whatever it is.
And I encourage you and exhort you to continue
to do that.
Let's look at people.
In our culture, people are very important.
And this is a proverb which reemphasizes it.
[speaking in Maori] He aha te mea nui?, He
tangata, he tangata, he tangata.
[translating] "What is the most important
thing in this world?
If you would ask me what is the most important
thing in this world, I would say to you, it
is people, it is people, it is people."
And on the first of March, 2004, some very
important people came and visited my home.
It was the person who would put this tattoo
-- this Ta Moko, Traditional Maori Tatoo
-- onto my face.
And he visited me in March, and I thought
he was visiting me to talk about putting my
Ta Moko on later in the year.
And as we sat at our family dinner together
with our two guests with us, he looked across
at me after we had our main meal, and he said
this, "Ngahi, I have my gear in the car."
Now remember, this had taken eight years of
planning and waiting.
And I'm thinking, "We're going to be doing
this in October. It's now March."
And he said, "Ngahi, I have my gear in the
car. We can do this tonight."
[pause] "Yes. Yes, I'm ready. I want to do
this tonight."
Suffice to say, I didn't get dessert that
night.
Eight o'clock at night until midnight; midnight
until four o'clock in the morning -- one night.
We got to midnight, and he said to me, "We
can take a break, and you can do this another
time. We can finish this another time if you
want."
And I said, "No, I waited eight years for
this. And I'm not leaving this house until
it's done."
And we finished the rest tonight.
So eight hours to put my tattoo onto my face.
This part of my tattoo -- my Ta Moko -- emphasizes
the importance of listening, which you are
doing so well now.
This part of my tattoo -- my Ta Moko -- emphasizes
the importance of seeing and observing and
looking.
There is nothing on my forehead to emphasize
the importance of thinking.
And on my chin is a pattern that looks like
a hammerhead shark [pause] on my chin.
And that is very significant to my tribe.
The name of the tribe that I come to you from
in New Zealand is called tiarowa.
And we are named after a shark.
And when our canoe left our original place
that we came from, it was caught in a whirlpool.
And the priest of our canoe said a prayer,
which enabled us to come out of the whirlpool
and at the same time a shark appeared.
And this shark led us -- not only out of the
whirlpool, but on to the resting place called
Maketu in the Bay of Plenty of New Zealand,
where our canoe rested.
In fact, this event with the shark was so
significant that, when we left here, we were
known as the [speaking in Maori]
It changed our name to become known as the
tiarowa people after that shark.
And we changed the name of our canoe as well
to 'The Tiarowa Canoe' before traveling on.
And so, this shark, known as the tiarowa shark,
is on my chin because of the importance of
speaking.
And as I work with leaders around the world
-- we've just come from Singapore and England
to be here today -- what I emphasize is that
leaders listen, look and observe, and think
before they speak.
Talking about my Ta Moko, which one -- and
looking like a leader is very important.
Which one looks more like a leader?
One of them is taken like this, with a camera
pointing at myself.
And the other one is taken by a professional
photographer.
As leaders, we need to be careful where our
image ends up, because -- as we all know -- it
can be on YouTube or anywhere within a split
second.
And beware of the roaming camera, especially
at those social functions that we tend to
attend.
Be aware of our image as leaders.
I was working in Quomu, and they gave me a
silver Pujo car to drive around in.
And I was driving down the street, saw this
sign, "Fresh scallops."
Thought, "Yep, that's me."
Pulled into a parking space, went to the shop,
and the shop was closed.
I thought, "Awh."
Came out, got in my car, it was a brand knew
Pujo they had given me.
Went to start the car, and the car wouldn't
start.
And I thought, "Awh, must be the alarm on
the keys."
Pulled the keys out, pushed the button, and
the car in front of me went [jin jin] I remember
looking at the key thinking, "Why would they
give you keys for two cars?" [laughter]
And then I thought, "Okay, let's try it again."
Put it in, start, wouldn't start, pull it
out, push the button, car in front went [ji]
Ah ha ha.
So I'm a bit slower than a lot of you here
in this room would have been.
Sure enough, looked around the car -- not
my car.
Get out of this car, enter the silver Pujo
in front of me -- this car was also silver
-- started up, took off.
Now, the funny thing was, when I got into
the first car, someone pulled up to take my
parking space.
So, can you imagine, I'm dressed in my suit
and Quomu, with my Ta Moko, them watching
all of this happening. [laughter]
Can you imagine the conversation at the police
station?
"Were there any distinguishing features?"
[laughter]
If we were in New Zealand, they would have
said, "Yes, he was Maori, and he was wearing
a suit." [laughter]
So, our appearance as leaders is very important,
and we only get one chance to make a first
impression -- one chance to make a first impression.
So do you look like a leader?
In fact, someone said to us, "Are you wearing
a tie?" Mark said to me, "You wearing a tie?
Do you think I should wear a tie?" I said,
"No. No, no.
I don't think anyone in Google will be wearing
a tie."
I said, "However, it's just a part of my presenting
and my branding that I wear a tie."
I said, "But, from what I've read about you
guys, you are just so busy pushing scooters
around, and doing all the thinking while you're
playing ping-pong and all the other things
that, Wow, why would you sweat with a tie
on?" So, do you look like a leader?
1987 -- I want to finish with looking at purpose
-- and 1987 was an important year in my life.
I was sitting on a hotel bed in a very nice
hotel.
And, as I'm sitting on this hotel bed, I'm
having a conversation that goes something
like this, "I have made it.
I have achieved every goal that I wanted to
achieve by the time I was thirty, and here
I am, 26 years of age."
So what were my five main goals?
The first goal was, we had lots of money in
the bank for our first house, had my first
degree under my belt -- my business degree
-- beautiful wife, even more beautiful car.
Someone asked me what that car was actually
one time.
And here I am in a high-flying job in a high-flying
career with a multinational oil company.
Life could not be any better.
In fact, I'm eating an egg burger, because
I'm sick of the restaurant food downstairs
that I've had to eat for the last three days.
And I'm at yet another leadership training
course.
Just nine short months later, I'm unemployed,
I've had to sell the beautiful car, we have
no money in the bank, and we are waiting for
friends who used to bring us food parcels.
So how did I go from a high-flying job to
being unemployed?
From "sick of the best food this world has
to offer" to "waiting for food parcels"?
No money in the bank, unemployed, sitting,
learning the Maori language.
I found myself in a setting very similar to
this where a speaker was talking, and he said,
"You know, we find it very hard to find Maori
leaders who will help us with the street kids
in the city of Oakland." which is our biggest
city -- and he said, "This is why.
Most of them get educated, end up in high-flying
jobs.
They have flash houses, flash cars -- very
beautiful houses, very beautiful cars.
And most of them end up marrying non-Maori
women."
This is a picture of my wife.
You can see the real thing which is a lot
better at the back later.
And it's a real privilege to be here with
my wife and family.
This is a picture of my wife, who obviously,
is not Maori.
And as this gentleman was saying that, he
said, "My boys call them mellow paths," which
is a biscuit that we have back home that's
a chocolate biscuit on the outside and white
on the inside.
And he said, "And all they do in the end is
they turn their backs on their own people."
And as he turned around, people started laughing.
I started crying.
I was sitting in the front seat, and I started
crying.
And I wept and wept and wept.
And I just could not stop weeping.
And after what seemed ages, he carried on
talking and I just couldn't stop weeping.
And I had to get up out of my seat and go
to another part of the whole, and my wife
followed me.
And she said, "Ngahi, are you all right?"
And I said, "No, I'm not."
I said, "I don't know who I am.
The goals that I had -- that I wanted to achieve
by the time I was thirty, have made me turn
my back on my people."
So what did that look like?
It meant going to university for a business
degree and passing papers in my language just
to pass papers, not actually to learn the
language.
And six months later -- not even knowing my
own language.
It meant my friend and my flatmate had a Maori
-- a group of guys that used to come around
our house into our flat and visit us.
And I used to go into my bedroom and pretend
I was studying, because I didn't want to know
these guys.
I'd become such an arrogant sod in the middle
of all of this career that, one day, a Maori
guy came up to me, and he said, [speaking
in Maori], [translating] "Have you got any
loose change?"
I said, "Man, I'm not your bro. I don't even
know who you are."
And he looked at me, and he goes, "Whatever."
He turned around and walked off.
It meant I didn't even know my own customs
and aspects of my own culture, and I had turned
my back on my culture.
And so, I found myself in the situation when
my wife said to me, "What would you like to
do?"
I said, "It needs to start with learning my
own language.
I need to know what it means to be Maori,
and I'd like to take a year off to learn the
Maori language."
And so, we both voluntarily took a year of
being unemployed and learning the Maori language.
And people have said, "Well, what's happened
since then?"
Let me share a couple of things about my beautiful
wife.
We've been married 24 years -- 25 years this
year, December the first.
After the one year of being unemployed, she
went to university and became the first person
in her family -- to our known knowledge -- to
receive a bachelors in arts, a degree from
a university.
She did her degree in Management Information
Systems and Maori Studies.
One day, she came back, and she said, "Ngahi,
when our children are born, I'd like us to
only speak Maori to them."
So, before our children were born, we made
a decision to only speak Maori.
They now attend a school, as I said earlier,
where Maori is the first language of instruction
and Google has helped them to search computers
in their official language -- a language that
one generation ago my parents were punished
for speaking in schools and were not allowed
to speak.
The term one generation, we've changed from
a people who were not allowed to speak our
own language to another generation who now
Google on a computer in their own language.
And I hope that emphasizes the importance
of what you have done for our language.
And I thank you again.
People have said, "What about you, Ngahi?"
Oh, my wife is fluent in Maori, sorry.
My wife is fluent in Maori, and she's been
adopted by my tribe.
And one of the discussions that took place
was, what's someone from our tribe saying,
When are you going to receive your mark of
leadership?
And if my Pakeha wife -- 'Pakeha' is the word
that we use for non-Maori in New Zealand -- if
my Pakeha wife can take some of the principles
that I've shared with you today about proverbs,
people, and purpose, to walk in my world,
then I know that you are more than able to
walk in your world.
People have said, "What about you, Ngahi?"
Obviously, I've changed my goals to one day
receive my mark of leadership, my gift from
my ancestors, my Ta Moko.
And I've shifted from a hotel room bed to
a room full of unemployed people to standing
here with you today.
And I've had the privilege of speaking in
many places around the planet about my message
of leadership.
And I'd like to emphasize the challenge to
you by saying and challenging you, Who might
you have turned your back on?
And what will you do different tomorrow as
a result of some of the things that I've been
able to share with you today?
Through proverbs and people, we establish
our purpose.
And I would now like to invite my son to join
me on the stage.
And we would like to issue you a challenge
from our people in New Zealand, which is called
a 'haka'
to emphasize the things that I have challenged
you about your leadership today.
Do you look like a leader? Do you think like
a leader?
What proverbs do you use?
It's not the size of the dog in the fight,
it's the size of the fight in the dog.
[speaking in Maori] Be strong. Be courageous.
Be steadfast.
And who might you have turned your back on?
And what will you do different tomorrow?
[chanting in Maori loudly]
From New Zealand, we thank you once. [speaking
in Maori]
We are honored to be here at Google.
We thank you twice. [speaking in Maori]
We thank you three times [speaking in Maori]
>> [Clapping]
>> [pause]
Ngahi Bidois: We -- just as the gentleman
is moving to the mic -- we unfortunately sold
out of books.
And it was a huge print run.
And I think it was about three hundred.
And we -- during this trip -- are getting
more books printed.
And we're only able to bring the last ten
books to Google unfortunately.
But would like to gift those ten books to
your company and we thank you _____ for hosting
us here.
And Erica [undecipherable]
Q First of all, thank you for speaking today.
And my question is, I love to travel, and
when I travel, I really enjoy seeing rituals
from indigenous people.
And I've been to New Zealand twice and really
enjoyed it.
When I was there, I went to -- and I'm probably
going to mispronounce this -- hongi?
Ngahi Bidois: Hongi, yes.
Q And the Maoris who perform some dancing
and whatnot were different from many of the
other indigenous groups that I've seen in
other places in the world, because they meant
it.
When they did what they did, they weren't
standing there doing it for tourists, they
meant it.
It was clear.
And my question for you is -- and it was beautiful.
I was obviously, I mean, they stood out from
many other peoples that I've seen.
My question is, Why do you think that the
Maori have been able to hold on to their culture
that strongly?
And what might other indigenous cultures learn
from you in that regard?
Ngahi Bidois: Thank you, Phil. Good question.
We -- a part of our survival if you want,
and a part of our business acumen has been
the expertise that we bring in the area of
tourism.
And I think there are two areas that contribute
to ascertaining our -- what we call 'performing
arts'.
One is, the emphasis of a culture that was
never written down.
It wasn't until we had people come from England
that our language, etcetera, was actually
written.
Our language was an old language that was
passed down through the generations.
And even the challenge, that my son and I
did then, is a challenge from our tribe that
has been passed down through many generations
and has retained a lot of our historical knowledge.
So that was the first thing.
The retention of our knowledge through our
performing arts has always been a very important
part of our culture.
The second one, obviously, is around tourism.
And we thought, "Well, you know, we are a
very unique culture from what we consider
a very unique and beautiful place."
And we were able to turn what had been historical
knowledge into tourism activity.
And so, we were not only able to perform our
challenges and our wiyat, our songs, but we
were also able to take that indigenous knowledge
and invite people to some of our very sacred
places.
And so, tourism, as you said, has always been
a part of who we are.
And an important part of our culture is hospitality.
An important part of our culture is being
able to look after the safety and look after
the well-being of our guests.
And tourism fits in that as well.
Now you mentioned hongi, Phil.
It's important that, when you are talking
about our language and use words like 'hongi',
that you don't get them confused with words
like 'hangi'.
Now a hongi is where I will greet you and
I will press noses with you.
But do you remember doing that?
I would like to demonstrate the hongi.
The hongi is where we press noses twice.
Now, we press noses with you once to acknowledge
you.
And twice to acknowledge your ancestors.
The pressing of the noses, known as the hongi,
allows us to both share a breath of life together
as we meet.
And it's a protocol that we use when we meet,
and also, when we leave someone.
So that's the hongi.
So the 'hongi' is where we meet you or greet
you.
And the 'hangi' is where we eat you and cook
you. [laughter]
You'll be pleased to know that we no longer
do that -- that there are other forms of meat
that have been provided that run around in
paddocks.
And that's called the 'hangi', but it's actually
a method of cooking food where it's prepared
under the ground; the ground is covered up
with stones that are heating in rocks, heating
the food, and it takes about three or four
hours to cook before we eat it.
It has a unique taste, doesn't it?
So does that answer your question?
So it's a retention of our knowledge -- our
indigenous knowledge -- and it's also the
ability to be business people.
We have in New Zealand -- Maori people have
some of the biggest tourism attractions in
New Zealand, from wild watching all the way
through to entertaining like you've seen here
tonight where you will have a hongi in performances
as well.
And especially in ______ the city that I come
from where it's known as the Maori cultural
capital of New Zealand, we also have some
of the biggest education institutes in New
Zealand.
And, for example, the biggest tertiary institute
is Maori.
We have scholarships for our young people.
And a lot of our tribes are receiving millions
of dollars from the crown in order for us
to develop our capacity in many areas throughout
New Zealand as well.
Other questions?
So I promise not to answer questions so long.
Q Thank you again for coming.
And it's very nice to meet you and listen.
I was just reading through some of the introduction.
And you're talking about your last name Bidois
and ______ French ancestry and raised Catholic.
Not knowing much about the Maori tribe and
religion, was there a conflict there?
Is there a similarity between, you know, with
other Maori tribes where there's Catholicism
or other types of religion blended in?
Just very curious.
Ngahi Bidois: Sure. And so your question is
around what sort of religion we have?
Q Yeah, is there, you know, is there a correlation
to perhaps a different way of having faith
or having belief since you talk -- at least,
you just bring it up in the book, coming from
primarily Catholic in the beginning.
Ngahi Bidois: Yes. As a people, we are very
spiritual.
I put it as 'spiritual'. As a people, we are
very spiritual people.
And we, for example, a part of the colonization
process if you want -- the people coming from
England -- was the first book that was ever
written in our language was the Bible.
And the Bible was written by missionaries
who came and were, I guess, obviously a part
of the religious beliefs that were brought
to our country.
As a people, we are very spiritual, and you
will find many of our Maori people distributed
amongst the many religions that are in New
Zealand.
For example, we have Catholics, Presbyterians,
Anglicans, and we also have more of the newer
forms of Christianity -- born again Christians,
etc.
And we also had our own prophets -- people
who had spiritual experiences and were healers.
People like William Ratner, who had followers
and who's today known as the Ratner Church
because of the things he was able to do and
the people that he healed and the gifts that
he presented to people in a spiritual sense.
And so, today, you'll find quite a wide range
of Maori involved in the various religions
as such.
However, we also have a very strong, spiritual
connection with our indigenous knowledge.
And our indigenous knowledge has within it
our own beliefs and our own creation and our
own guardians, our own -- we would call him
'Supreme Being'.
Our own supreme being.
And known as [speaking in Maori] [translating]
"The Fatherless One."
And many other names.
We would also have guardians at a lower spiritual
plane who are guardians over areas.
And, for example creation, which has helped
us hugely with our environmental protocols
and the way that we look after our environment.
So spirituality is a very strong part of who
we are as Maori.
And, like I said, there's a wide range of
people you'll find -- Maori people in different
beliefs.
Other questions? [pause] Cool. Thank you.
>> [Clapping]